I'm joined today by mark Rosenberg who's
the founding director of the CDC's
National Center for injury prevention
and control also a retired assistant
Surgeon General Mark it's great to have
you back you know there have been some
changes reported in the in media about
the extent to which the government and
CDC can research gun violence this is a
topic that's been very controversial for
some time so let's start sort of with
the basic facts what has changed and
what hasn't changed with regard to the
CDC's ability to research gun violence
well thanks David this is really an
important topic I think what has changed
is that people are starting to
understand how important it is to bring
science back into this issue and what
happened was marked in the last omnibus
appropriations bill that was passed by
Congress and then signed by the
President and this bill had language in
it that quoted the new secretary
secretary a czar of Health and Human
Services
he said the Dickey amendment does not
prohibit CDC from researching gun
violence prevention that was a very big
step because there was a lot of
misunderstanding before people thought
that the Dickey amendment was a
prohibition on the research and it
absolutely was not what it was was when
it was passed it was a compromised in
1996 the compromise between the NRA net
faction which wanted to shut down the
whole Injury Center and stop the
research and those people in Congress
who wanted the research to go on the
compromise was the wording of the Dickey
amendment that said none of these funds
that go to CDC can be used to promote or
advocate gun control it didn't say
anything about research and in fact CDC
was not in the business of advocating
gun control now that's becoming clear
and that position had
endorsement from the Trump
administration and from Congress it was
a very big and important step so
strictly speaking the CDC never was
actually banned from doing research on
gun violence but politically there was
an environment in which effectively is
it fair to say they were doing no such
research well CDC had been doing the
research but the NRA got very angry at
CDC because the first research study
that CDC published looked at the
question of whether having a gun in your
home makes you safer as the NRA
advertised they said if you care about
your family's safety you'll have a gun
in your home if you're a real man you'll
have a gun in your home so CDC looked at
the question of whether in fact having a
gun in your home made you safer and what
we found was that having a gun in your
home not only didn't it make you safer
but in increase the risk that someone in
your home would die from a gun homicide
not by a little bit not by 10 or 20
percent but by 200 percent that's a huge
increase in risk and then increased the
risk of that someone would die from gun
suicide by 5 times or 400% the NRA
didn't like that and got very angry and
wanted to get CDC out of the business
they told people everyone in Congress
and all of their members that you have a
choice either you do the research or you
keep your guns but you can't do both so
they mounted a huge campaign against CDC
and the Dickey amendment was basically a
shot across the bow that said if you do
research in this area we will make your
life miserable
yeah by directing a letter to you
stating you're violating the terms so
there's a concern about the language
that now is present about this which is
that it appears at least to limit the
the ways in which the funding can be
used
examining the causes of gun violence but
arguably restricting or preventing the
CDC from looking at ways to prevent or
solve the issue of gun violence is that
relevant because you did say just a few
minutes ago that that's not typically
what the CDC would do anyway that's not
really the business that they're in so
is that concern about the language
relevant or not I don't think that's a
legitimate restriction on the scope of
the research the restriction says CDC
can't lobby for gun control legislation
CDC never has and doesn't intend to
lobby what they intend to do is
basically look at the research to answer
four simple questions what's the problem
what are the causes what works to
prevent it and how do you scale it up
and translate it into legislation and
policy and I don't think there's any
restriction on that you've been
following this issue for a very very
long time do you believe that since the
parklands shooting and the huge influx
of student activism and sort of a
renewed interest in this topic which we
often see after a mass shooting but it
seems to be happening even more right
now do you think anything is actually
different in terms of the sort of
legislative and elected official will to
actually make changes and deal with this
at this point or do you see it as mostly
political posturing oh no I think
there's there's been a real shift and
two things have happened one is I think
people are starting to understand what
does research have to do with getting us
out of this horrible horrible deadly
morass people understand that research
can lead us out in five ways that will
work to both reduce gun violence and to
protect gun rights if you take guns out
of the hands of people who've already
been convicted of domestic violence
felonies are misdemeanors you're not
interfering with the rights of
law-abiding gun owners there are many
ways to differentiate who has guns and
to start to take them out of the hands
of people who legally should not have
them so there are ways to do both and I
think
it's become clear that it's not either
or it's not either prevent gun violence
through research or keep your guns but
there are ways to do both so that's a
big difference the second thing is that
I think even the people in the gun
rights camp don't want their children to
be killed at school they don't want
their children to be killed at shopping
malls or at waffle houses or at concerts
no one wants that no one wants to live
in fear of mass killings no one wants to
see veterans committing gun suicide
whether you're pro-gun rights or pro-gun
control yeah I mean know what I
generally agree with that here's my
concern though mark right like let's I
attribute good faith to the overwhelming
majority of the people that are on the
side of gun rights it's not that they
they they want to prevent kids from
being killed and isn't people from being
killed of course they do the part where
I think it gets complex is they don't
see some kids being killed or some
innocent people people being killed or
whatever as enough to override the
Second Amendment as they perceive it in
context of sort of America and the
Constitution so it's not to me an issue
of they're indifferent to the deaths of
kids it's that they see the actions that
some want to take myself included to
protect kids and innocent people as
pushing too far or pushing too hard
against the Second Amendment and I don't
know how we can actually have a
productive conversation if that's
someone's point of view I think there
are people who still believe what the
old NRA leadership told them that if you
do this research you will lose all your
guns what's becoming clear is that
that's not true this was a lie that was
fed to the membership and to legislators
by the NRA leadership who wanted to stop
the research at all costs and now I
think NRA members overwhelmingly want to
do this
search to find ways that can both
protect their rights and reduce gun
violence I think that's a big change and
it's not either/or in fact if we don't
do the research we probably won't be
able to protect gun rights as well as we
could if we do the research and find out
what works to do both there are so many
ways to do both and the research is the
way to find them what's the lowest
hanging fruit in terms of actions that
could be taken that are both politically
viable and sort of legally tenable is it
background checks is it the domestic
violence exemptions like where would you
go first well I think there are a lot of
areas to start one is waiting periods it
turns out that a lot of people who
commit suicide especially young people
do it on an impulse something bad
happens they have a big problem at
school they break up in a serious
relationship or their parents do
something to them that they don't like
and they rush out buy a gun and shoot
themselves it turns out in a study of
people who almost killed themselves but
survived that most of the young people
who shot themselves and missed their
heart or missed the critical brain parts
most of them had been thinking of
suicide not for a year not for months
not for weeks for five minutes
if you can keep them from rushing out
and buying a gun when they have that
impulse you can save their lives and you
can do this without infringing at all on
the rights of law-abiding gun owners the
NRA in another example for a long time
has said that there are laws on the
books that we need to enforce so let's
find out how we get better reporting of
people who've been convicted of domestic
violence felonies or misdemeanors right
who shouldn't be allowed to buy guns the
shooter in Sutherland Texas the Air
Force messed up they didn't report him
there many
other cases that don't get reported how
do we find out how to implement the laws
and make them effective how do we
separate guns in the hands of people who
are criminals who've been convicted of
major felonies who shouldn't have guns
how to actually get them out of their
hands and keep them out of their hands
extreme risk people who have threatened
to kill themselves how do we get guns
out of their hands and keep them out of
their hands for as long as they're at
risk
these are just three ways that we can
both protect gun rights and prevent gun
violence and there are many more ways
waiting to be discovered through
research we can't say what research
we'll find but if we set out to find
those things that will both protect gun
rights and prevent gun violence we'll
find them
we'll find them and they will get us out
of this and we'll be able to tell
lawmakers who right now are asked to
vote on things without knowing whether
they're safe or effective we'll be able
to tell them here are the data No
we might say it's not safe to arm all
teachers because maybe research shows
you'll kid kill more kids instead of
saving more lives maybe we'll give them
the data that they need to pass smart
legislation so there are many things
that will both protect gun rights and
prevent gun violence let's start finding
them we've been going far too long
without knowing what they are but
they're there for science to find we've
been speaking with mark Rosenberg
founding director of CDC's National
Center for injury prevention and control
also a retired assistant Surgeon General
mark great to talk to you again thanks
very much David it's an important
message you have to get out appreciate
it